all right Ron to you here we go also
thank you to just inhale that's trash we
got new trace your skin so I can't be
that upset I guess
hot dupes I think that's new that's
praising you that's the third mercies oh
this that's the new spray is this a play
on booty oohs from wrestling does anyone
watch wrestling new day new day I think
this is a booty owes reference I'm sit
this is the third mercy skin we've
gotten third one it's cool though not
not saying it's not cool got another
Brazil no new voice line double
legendary yah we in there we got double
legendaries boys we got the Brazil lucio
got the got the gloves in case you gotta
play some goalie we got a firefighter
rescue me even though that's not new
i've never seen a double legendary skin
though that's pretty sick John Cena you
can't see me alright this is going way
better than earlier five boxes in we
have two legendary skins and one is a
Olympic skin which is awesome I'll show
mercy again later you uh Carlton watches
wrestling cool I watched a little bit of
raw last night we got like a judo or
Taekwondo zenyatta which is weird seeing
him use his speed actually and we got um
i guess like is this like the diving
contest roadhog we can uh let's equip
someone knows why not I was Taekwondo
there you go got on the first try um
wrestling reinhardt a little faster I
know people are like oh we want to see
the good stuff I'll legendary
ah what is this the Dukes are real what
are the odds this both times now we've
gotten duplicate Olympic skins and it's
just worth trash 200 200 credits sad
oh come on give me that America give me
that America McCree WD HW is fake as AF
that's true ah that's not a that's not a
it's not a McCree or torbjörn oh we got
the boxing emote again I'll show you
guys because you didn't see it earlier
pretty good pretty good soon alright
pretty good emo Trevor a new spray
bicycle or as our new player icon
bicycle diva triathlete
yes we got that torbjörn all we need is
like Kenji McCree and Azaria Olympic
skin and we in there we in there Swedish
engineering it's got on his handler all
right all right so far these boxes are
like so much better than the last set of
boxes I think it's like blizzard knew I
spent more money if that's useless this
is this is useless Hey oh so there's a
different icon and we can be basketball
fair a slam dunk
symetra player icon I think this is a
new spray as well at the may ping pong
spray duplicate Oh what no I thought
there was like a white version of the
diva dang it I was like the is there a
skin that I don't know well you show all
the skins I'll go back at the end we
show some of the newer stuff yeah just
Stoops there
more trash
we got a junk rat tennis icon females
tennis that's a duplicate may gold medal
victory pose okay now we're getting into
the dumpsters right now oh no why don't
give me gold man I guess this is better
than getting a dupe though this is get
it better than getting a dupe but there
are legendaries and epics games there's
only six legendaries to Lucio's tues
Arya's to tracers they're just
alternates and then there's a cook
there's like one epic for wanting yes
yes yes for Russia I'm toggle we in
there we got one of each now guys we got
one of each we got one of each now we
need to get that McCree in that Genji
what is up mr. Vic alright alright 26
dude these boxes have been so much
better so much better
maybe I should stop jinxing myself I'm
sorry if I'm complaining it's just how I
get one
oh hey we got a we got a highlight intro
bicycle do that intro is pretty sweet
now we just need to get that emote I'm
surprised it doesn't have my skin though
for some reason but alright that's
pretty cool it's pretty cool these boxes
have been good now we need mcrae mcrae
and Genji I think that might be all
that's left oh we got another legendary
so biker to your be one it's pretty good
and I'll show you guys this a shot put
highlighting show chunk at we it's a
duplicate it's pretty good oh we got a
UH Egypt flag or player icon
goes to trace your skin's I'll show it
to you guys after we open the boxes
using on a skin it's nothing new though
I nothing doing this box are there oh oh
we got that Reaper ass BMX spray you
know 20 more boxes guys can we get
another legendary feel like we've been
getting pretty lucky already though all
we want is that my cream that gangi
though we don't need legendaries
necessarily anymore we need a hose like
ash or you can or upper cut tiger
skeet shooting probably yeah or just
shooting oh that's new too that's kind
of a dark who what's this new Bonnie
player icon Ron are like last 15 posted
no I really wanted to beat McCree cream
USA machree it was like a tease cuz it
sees may is Bay I do not dispute that
man's day oh we gotta lucio we got it we
got the emote alright so we got all
three now velutio things it's pretty
cool iskcon there this spray is pretty
hilarious the that's where he hides all
the shotguns
who got the swedish flag fire icon last
13 a shot foot again it's like the
fourth one a lot of dupes
a lot of dupes now legendary we got a we
got a duplicate this is our third diva
Korea Korea diva and we got another not
another legendary junker that was very
cool though I like that one I think
that's Dave Jewett's favorite will show
it will go through them after that's
open those was this the purple sure
that's not new though I don't think
just any more boxes I'll go through the
rest of skins and then we'll fight wrap
the team when they play one more game
always strive for improvement here that
stream always strive for improvement pro
tip from mr. zenyatta
more dupes
more dupes I actually don't expect too
much out of these last five because we
had such good luck oh we got the other
tracer though this set of boxes has been
insane this one's cooler than the track
and field alone in my opinion alright
we've gotten pretty lucky can't be upset
at whatever else we get this has been
magical more dupes you know what would
be sick though I'm asking for a lot out
of these two last boxes but see we got
the Genji voice line now we gotta get
the Genji skin how he was hoping for a
challenge I was hoping for a challenge
to
I was the sweetest your yard I saw an
epic i was like maybe my prediction
would come true but it did not well we
have one more box today oh oh my god USA
machree we got us a McCree we didn't get
Genji but we pretty much got all the
skins we wanted that is insane